yeah i'm pretty much out of tea
look at how much tea is left
almost none
so let's play one more game
new game
playing wessel hk
oh
ten plus five
opponents rated
23.21
[Music]
no stafford
okay let's treat this seriously let's
play
let's play chess
yeah no stafford no traxler
a tardov forcing me to finish my tea
so yeah hopefully this will be an
instructive
final game
i'm playing a knight tango
this has been my
line of choice recently
oh dear we have another
chance
g3 i'll play e5
i can play this but i think i want to
play this first
unless it's actually an interesting
decision
let's play chess let's play chess let's
play chase let's play chess let's play
chess let's play chess let's play chess
let's play chess let's play chess let's
play chess let's play chess let's play
chess let's play chess
let's play chess pog champ my challenge
oh
[Music]
pog champ
yeah the tts is beginning
[Music]
i think break in some way
okay so
uh this is actually a very typical
structure of the night's tango
mexican defense
got my knights on the king's side they
can help defend
and or attack
yeah i'll put the bishop on c5 that's
one of the reasons why i didn't play
bishop b4 because i wanted the option
of
yeah of having this sort of attacking
setup
and if white tries to destroy my bishop
i can throw an a5
try and maintain the bishop along this
diagonal
r2d2 says beep boop beep
whoa
[Music]
beep boop beep b4
b4 is actually a really clever move
if i take it i lose a bishop
so i think i have to play this
thankfully c5 i can take and i think
that's okay
a4 okay i'll play a5
b5 wow
and now i'll castle
so the queensland closed down which i
don't mind
white does have a bit more space but
there's not really a great way to make
further progress
and now i can try and focus on the king
side
somehow maybe didn't understand what was
going on until you said let's play chess
i thought this was yahtzee
i'm glad i could clarify for you
it's a question what to do with this
bishop
hello fellow human i am a human just
like you are human
it's nice to be human and do human
things such as being made of human flesh
yes
ah man
i could do robot things h5h4h3
alpha zero style
[Music]
what to do here
maybe h6
to start
h6 preventing bishop g5
because this plan could have been
annoying
h6 also enables knight h7 and
f5
i think i'll start with this move
because i want to play queen c8 and
prevent the setup from light
and also have the option of playing
bishop h3
so
yeah there's a few resources
between queen c8 between this and this
my pieces are relatively happy here
oh no
brad mcclellan's son
[Music]
won't stop saying let's play chess now
that's what happens when we do a chant
at mikhail balakov i'm going to need to
see you completely chess checkmate in
one capture
uh yeah we have to
see who's human and who's a bot
okay now knight g4
[Music]
looks really nice
because i'm hitting up to discouraging
this move
and enabling f5
the problem with white committing to
this structure so early
is
like usually white's plan is to
eventually prepare c5
now c5 i just went upon
[Music]
so i kind of have to just sit
like a duck
ah
pam says this is a heck of a way to make
a living
yeah it's my career now
when people quack at me
and
spam the same words
meanwhile i'm just
trying gambit stuff
okay this move looks really interesting
this takes takes
oh i don't have e4 in the end though
if i take
um
yeah rookie 2 i guess was useful for
white
like a duck hunk
i think you mean quack
bishop e3
i'm realizing this game is going to be
more difficult than
i was imagining a few moves ago
the same words
oh yeah that's
i guess a literal
interpretation
i'm thinking 97 actually
leaving tension if takes takes and c4 is
kind of weak
there is c5 in that line
[Music]
but maybe i just move back
and c6
takes
another possibility is takes and take
with the c pawn get the c file
wait a minute
play this there's g4
and then my thing gets trapped
yeah i was about to blunder a bishop
there
97 is not a good move
maybe queen c8 first
king h2
[Music]
want another chance at youtube level
content i got you kappa
ah
maybe you'll have to play rasta boss
after this game
[Music]
tempting my uh my curiosity
okay so i'm leaving the tension because
i think
the trade on b6 would favor me
even though the structure kind of looks
ugly
c4 would be very weak
so king h2 expected
how to do this
this night's misplaced
i haven't moved knight h8
to misplace it even more
i should consider this move but it just
gives away too much and
creates a weakness
i don't know what to do here
well it's actually played a decent
number of positional moves the last few
moves
look at this move work off saturn
embrace your new role as duck king
become spokesperson for ducks marry a
duck negotiate the hostile duck takeover
quack
wait what
duck king
not to be confused with ducking
the act of
the act of ducking
how did the fine ducking
the act of dodging a duck
so i played rook f7 to someday like
double up and use my f-file
i also played it to make way for the
night so my bishop has breathing room
quack to my lord and master the
spokesperson of ducks quack quack quack
i don't know what i'm supposed to say so
that's
quack
yeah i want to keep the structure
the same
everything's really solid
sometimes in chess
mistakes are made when you don't know
what to do and you try and do the wrong
thing
so we might be at a standstill
just give chat more time to quack
ah
i think there's because of this
prediction
all the doubters are trying to distract
me
there was a prediction going on whether
i would win three games in a row i've
won two this is the third game
didn't know chess could be this
entertaining
wait chess or
quacking
opponent wants to control e4
okay knight d2 is a good move
yeah i think i'll play knight f8 this is
original plan
oh no it's another quack chance
in case this goes on youtube
this is what all the youtube video
all the youtube viewers are missing
oh no
quack quack quack quack
quack quack quack quack quack
quack quack quack quack quack quack
quack quack quack quack quack quack
quack quack quack quack quack quack
quack quack quack quack quack quack
man it slowed down and sped up
that's slightly terrifying
okay at least my night got to a happier
place
it's actually kind of doing things
this is actually serious business you
have to get these people to stop
distracting you might lose this
i'm trying to stay focused but it's
difficult
don't get distracted our predictions
i'm i'm trying my best
again i haven't lost a game this year
i'm trying to keep up the streak
the white's playing well
okay f4 f4 is another like typical
positional move
now i
i have to consider taking but that gives
away the d4 square
so another consideration is queen f8
if i
oh i could take with i could take the
bishop
first and then if takes takes takes
i take on c4
if takes takes takes takes
and f4 is weak i'll take the bishop
first
f4 it maybe favors me more than white
i mean this move is really scary
more scary than all the quacks
because then if i move my bishop the
night just gets in
i don't want to be a sitting duck
realizing knight h5 i just lose a knight
so
knight c5
maybe knight c5 knight t4 and then like
bishop d7
i don't mind the trade
so i might just hunker down
okay we got some emote only mode
that's kind of soothing
can think in silence
kind of
oh no
yeah white has control over the only
open file
i'm thinking queen f8 idea queen d6
also trying to discourage pawn d6
upon d6 is maybe a consideration last
move
okay
got my pieces lined up
connect four very powerful connect four
very tense position
now this battery is
it's scary looking but i'm controlling
most of the
infiltration squares
b6
trying to turn my pawns into a y shape
i
think i take that i mean i could start
with this though
maybe i'll start with this
allowing
[Music]
it's confusing so i'm allowing rookie 8
but i always have luft i have the f8
square for rook
and here i can take with check first
it gets really unclear though
[Music]
okay rook g3 i have this
now i want to take on c7 and probably
with a rook
workout three might be coming
also this cool move
that's probably not so cool
d6
uh probably work here
yeah now the d5 square is open
this is turning into
this complete chaos
i'm feeling okay though because i have
safety
i have a blockade
d6 is arguably more weak than it is
strong
hey pam finally has some good internet
and la nayana likes using words
this is a twitch chat right now
oh this chat
oh rook f3
rook f3 i was looking at actually
there's queen d4
takes takes and then the knight's
hanging but also the bishop's hanging
i don't know what's going on
maybe just queen g5
i can't take on d6
consider taking on c4 though
i gotta move quicker too
[Music]
oh this is confusing
i think i take on c4
i mean a lot of things are hanging now
this rook really holds the position
together
an idea is to eventually queen trade and
win in the endgame
yes and there's my b5
i probably have to move the bishop
knight b5 bishop e4
but then rook
and there's so much craziness
this position is competing with twitch
chat in terms of how crazy it can be
i'm up two pawns
but white has a lot of potential energy
it's b7 pawn
i'm realizing i might have the threat of
taking
deflecting the queen from the rook but
that wouldn't apply within that goes to
b5
another line i was just looking at is
takes takes rookie 7 takes takes in
queen e3
taking up the pawn
so knight b5 is played
if i was thinking oh bishop before
there's rook f6
so what to do
maybe just bishop g6
rook g3
oh what to do
i'm just trying to hold on oh no did i
blunder
i maybe wonder but i'm not sure
i definitely overlooked a move
okay we're both getting low on time
it's not over till it's over
and lights up a minute
i'm thinking silently now
oh
i really don't know what's going on
white taking a lot of time it's critical
moment
a4 is undefended
oh free food
yeah
okay so
if i took the rook there is bishop d5
bishop d3 it's kind of just desperation
but it's interesting desperation
because now both rooks are attacked
if rook moves back somewhere
i take bishop d5 i move over and takes
takes
and life goes on
that's a good move
oh a4 was not
hanging
oh dear i'm in trouble again
or still
i have to take
so at least i'm pinning the bishop
d7 rook d8
this is gonna be close
both very long time
queen f4
check
at least my rooks are well placed queen
is well placed
on d7
play queen g3
that's a good move
i'm still in trouble
i'm trying my best to resist here
thank you doctor
i actually don't have to take right away
i will though
here i have amazing move f5
wow
all three results are still possible
though
i could still lose this could be a draw
on time
[Music]
uh let's
take how to do this i have this move too
[Music]
now let's take first
thankfully this is not legal
turning f5 now
wow
[Music]
oh no
i blundered
why did i
oh thanks for reading chess brainiac
i'm joining at a very intense moment
i blundered
oh no
[Music]
i might not lose this
to play this
opponent was so tricky with a knight
there
now does the opponent know how to check
me with bishop and knight
this could be a long game
[Music]
when they're taking their time
that's unexpected
i'm gonna offer to draw
okay now i'm playing for a win because
it seems like opponent's not so
confident
um
well almost
i've almost flag lagged
somehow
to be careful with the lag
i might as well push the a pod
[Music]
give my opponent a choice
i think it's going to be a draw
yeah
what a game
i could have won though
with uh the bishop knight
i meant to take the knight but it
doesn't matter
we'll play it out
okay it's a draw
my first draw of 2022
yeah that does mean two and a half out
of three
i'm still undefeated
i haven't won all my games
pg f8 what a crazy move
yeah because it's hard to stop
i guess i should just move my rook
though
i should just move my rook double the
viewers from my last youtube game come
on eric you know you want to
okay
i'll i'll if i if i remember in a moment
i'll play rasta boss
but i
yeah i blundered away the game with c2
i should just move the rook anywhere
but kudos to my opponent being tricky
move 63
i could have
queened oh yeah if i queen it's it's a
draw
because the bishop will stop this pawn
the king will stop this pawn
so what to do
um well i could have won
wait where was it
oh it's here like white has a fortress
so white could just start moving the
king in and win all the pawns
i there's nothing i could do
i don't even know what i was going to do
maybe move the king this way
but the knight in bishop works so well
to cover
the squares
yeah like this whole all of these furs
are off limits from the minor pieces
so
yeah this is the best chance but it
would still be a matter of checkmating
with bishop knight
which is sometimes difficult in time
pressure
how do you mate with a knight and bishop
oh maybe i'll share
okay let me share
can i win from this position against
stockfish
okay challenge i will be white
level eight
one minute no increments
might mess this up but we'll see
um yeah we'll try and win the pawn first
so we can clean up the pawns
and then
here comes the bishop knight checkmate
let's win the other pawn first
actually there's no need
actually maybe there is a need
okay so i'll win the pawn
oh the pawns being annoying
come back here
stop it
my knight's on the wrong square
okay here here we're gonna see how to
check me with bishop knight
oops i already messed up
oops
ah
no
there we go
oh apparently barely
that's how you do it